بعد ما صارت مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بشكل
جزء كبير من حياتنا صار اي شيء بدنا نزله
لازم يكون كثير حريرين وعارفين منيح شو
ممكن يعمل من ردود افعال خصوصا اذا كان
عندنا متابعين بالملايين لحد هون احنا عم
نحكي بشكل عام لكن موضوعنا عن نجم المنتخب
المصري وليفربول الانجليزي محمد صلاح صلاح
قبل بيوم نشر صوره هو وعائلته الصغيره
امام شجره عيد الميلاد بمنزله لكن بعدها
الصوره اثار محمد صلاح حيرت متابعيه
بفيديو جديد بيطلع فيه على وشك القفز من
طياره هيلوكبتر مقطع الفيديو نشروه صلاح
باستخدام خاصي او نشر وصلاح باستخدام
خاصيه الاستوري على حسابه في الانستغرام
داخل استوديو تصوير قاعد بمدخل الطياره
وعلى وشك القفز وفي ناس من تحت بتشجعوا
على القفز خلينا نشوف مع بعض عن اي فيديو
يا صلاح
المقطع اثار حيره متابعين محبوب مصر
بخصوصا بخصوصا اذا كان المقطع هو جزء من
حمله دعائيه او من مسلسل درامي او من فيلم
سينمائي كان هناك كثير من الاسئله خصوصا
لانه صلاح شارك بكثير من الحملات الدعائيه
لشركات وبيوت ازياء لكن الحيره كانت انه
صلاح بحياته وشارك في اعمال الدراميه سواء
بالسينما او بتليفزيون ولحد الان ما في اي
رد من صلاح باكد او بينفي الموضوع